hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
heute gibt es einen schokoladen-nobic
Cheesecake Bananen Schokoladen
Croissants und einen eisblocker
[Musik]
ich werde heute alle Rezepte mit dieser
bon Marmore Haselnuss und kakao-creme
Zubereiten ihr kennt alle vielleicht
Bonbon von diesem Fruchtaufstrichen oder
Marmeladen und das ist wirklich eine
Firma die man auch immer mit guter
Qualität verbindet weil sie einfach
tolle Rezepturen aus Frankreich haben
und alle diesen karierten Deckel also
Clara Wiedererkennungswert und von
bonamore gibt's auch eine Haselnuss
Kakao Creme die einfach richtig lecker
ist die kann ich euch wirklich sehr
empfehlen weil sie auch zum einen ohne
palmöl ist 20% Haselnüsse enthält die
riecht man auch schon wenn man das Glas
öffnet weil es einfach nach richtig
leckeren frisch gerösteten Haselnüssen
riecht eine tolle cremige Konsistenz hat
und das ist nicht nur ein toller Bruder
Aufstrich sondern eben auch eine tolle
Zutat mit der ihr backen könnt mit der
Getränke verfeinern könnt mit der ihr
die leckersten Dessert er war zubereiten
könnt und daraus werde ich jetzt heute
drei leckere Rezepte zubereiten ich
würde sagen ich starte direkt mit dem
ersten Rezept mit dem nobak Schokoladen
[Musik]
für den Knusperboden verwende ich 200
Gramm Schokoladen Butterkekse 160 g
Zartbitterkuvertüre 40 Gramm Butter und
für die Creme 400 Gramm Frischkäse 200g
bon Marmore Haselnuss und Kakaocreme 40
Gramm Kakao 400 g Schlagsahne und seiner
Fahrt zum steif schlagen zuerst nehmt
ihr jetzt eure Kuvertüre ich habe hier
Kuvertüre Chips deswegen muss ich sie
nicht hacken falls ihr Kuvertüre am
Block habt einfach kurz hacken in ein
schmelzen füllen und dann über dem
warmen Wasserbad schmelzen oder auch
gerne in der Mikrowelle bei niedriger
Stufe und solange die hier noch schmilzt
kann ich schon mal die Kekse zerkleinern
muss sagen ich habe es mir irgendwann
angewöhnt immer drunter zu nehmen weil
entweder Töpfe Rührschüssel oder auch
diese Schälchen einfach verrutschen und
so arbeitet sich echt besser als so
drunter
die einfach kurz zerkleinern geht auch
mit einem ausrollstab geht auch in einem
Mixer oder einfach hier mit dem Rocker
dann könnt ihr jetzt hier noch die
Butter dazu geben die schmilzt noch in
der Restwärme und dann einfach beides
vermischen Butter Schokolade und
Keksbrösel und dann nehme ich jetzt hier
eine Backfolie und ein Blech was gut in
den Kühlschrank passt meinen Backrahmen
ihr könnt auch gerne einen Backring
verwenden falls ihr eine Runde Torte
machen wollt und jetzt kommen hier die
Brösel rein und werden schön flach
gedrückt entweder mit einem Glas oder
z.B auch mit der burgerpresse und da
könnt ihr jetzt einfach schon mal die
kalte Schlagsahne mit seiner
Fahrstreifen dann nehme ich mal einen
Teelöffel pro 100 ml Sahne Sahne steif
jetzt kann ich hier den Frischkäse mit
der Creme verrühren ich habe jetzt die
hier schon abgehoben also 200 g und man
sieht auch wirklich sofort die ist so
cremig und streichfähig und riecht
einfach nur richtig lecker dann noch
Kakao dazu und etwas Salat und dann kurz
berühren gar nicht so lange sondern
wirklich nur so lange bis sich alles
verbunden hat und dann kommt jetzt hier
noch vorsichtig die Sahne dazu
wird untergehoben bzw einfach nur ganz
kurz eingerührt
und dann kommt die leckere Creme direkt
auf den Crunch Boden und wird
verstrichen und eigentlich war es das
auch schon fast am Ende kommt dann
nämlich noch von Mama Creme drauf und
das ist so und jetzt einfach nur
abdecken
und ab in den Kühlschrank
jetzt ist der Cheesecake schön fest ich
löse sie noch gleich raus und dann werde
ich über den Cheesecake noch ein
bisschen one Kakao Creme drüber Dritteln
das heißt ich nehme jetzt hier die Creme
und erwärmen Sie entweder in der
Mikrowelle bei niedriger Stufe oder ihr
macht es einfach über dem warmen
Wasserbad
das sieht richtig gut aus okay ihr könnt
jetzt entweder Rechtecke schneiden ihr
könnt Raupen schneiden ihr könnt sie
groß oder klein schneiden ganz wie ihr
möchtet yummy die sehen super aus
die sehen so gut aus und hier kommt
jetzt einfach
Creme drüber
[Musik]
also dann probiere ich mal den
Cheesecake boah das ist so eine tolle
Konsistenz
[Musik]
sondern auch einen richtig tollen
Geschmack definitiv empfehlenswert der
Cheesecake ist gemacht jetzt kommt
direkt Rezept Nummer zwei nämlich
Schokoladen Bananen
dafür braucht ihr einfach nur zwei
Bananen eine Rolle Blätterteig etwas bon
marmorcreme und ein Ei das habe ich
jetzt hier schon mal verquiriert den
Blätterteig holt ihr am besten so 10 bis
15 Minuten vor der Verwendung aus dem
Kühlschrank heraus dann ist er nämlich
nicht brüchig die Butter wird ein
bisschen weich und dann kann man ihn
richtig schön ausrollen
und den schneidet jetzt in Streifen die
sollen so ungefähr 2 cm breit sein
könnten Pizza Rad nehmen ein Messer oder
auch ein bisschen glatt dann die Banane
schälen
und so ein bisschen oben aushöhlen ich
habe jetzt hier so einen Paprika
hautentferner ihr könnte doch einfach
ein Teelöffel nehmen oder ein Messer
einfach das jetzt hier ein bisschen
Schokocreme reinpasst das könnt ihr
gerne naschen und ihr tiefer hier die
Mulde ist umso mehr Schokoladencreme
passt rein
da füllt ihr jetzt eure Creme rein
sind übrigens die besten Löffel um
schokoladengläser
[Musik]
jetzt nehmt ihr euch hier die
Teigstreifen und umwickelt die Banane
ich fange jetzt hier einfach mal mittig
an
und immer mit der Naht nach unten und so
überlappend einfach einwickeln damit die
Schokoladencreme auch nicht rausläuft
vielleicht kennt ihr auch das eine
Gericht das nennt sich ein bisschen im
Schlafrock das ist wenn man kleine
Würstchen in Teig einpackt umwickelt und
im Ofen backt dann hat man nämlich auch
im Schlafrock was herzhaftes
und hier vorne dann einfach schön
verschließen dann auch hier soll er der
Bananensaft nicht auslaufen wenn euch
eine Banane zu groß ist und den kleinere
Snacks machen wollt dann könnt ihr auch
einfach halbieren aber man kann es auch
nach dem Backen eine Rolle Blätterteig
reicht bei mir jetzt exakt für zwei
Bananen und die bestreiche ich dir jetzt
einfach mit dem Ei stellt sie dann in
den Backofen bei 180 Grad ober
Unterhitze und da brauchen sie je nach
Größe der Bananen etwa 25 Minuten bis
sie schön goldbraun sind
wow
oh ja
und da drüben wir jetzt noch mal
Haselnuss Kakao Creme drüber ich habe es
jetzt hier einfach über dem warmen
Wasserbad noch mal erwärmt ihr könnt
aber auch wenn euer Glas schon fast leer
ist das Glas einfach ins Wasserbad
stellen geht genug
okay
[Musik]
wollt ihr probieren
vorsicht heiß
aber man muss wirklich aufpassen
man darf sich nicht verbrennen unser
Bananen schokoladencroissant essen wir
jetzt noch kurz auf und dann zeige ich
euch noch ein Getränk was so lecker ist
wir machen gleich noch einen Eis Mokka
und dafür braucht ihr jetzt erstmal
einen Kaffee entweder nehmen jetzt eine
Tasse lasst den Kaffee reinlaufen oder
ihr nehmt einfach euer fast leeres
bonamore glass und lass dir den Kaffee
reinlaufen
Kaffee Crema
jetzt einfach das Glas verschließen
schauen dass es richtig verschlossen ist
und schütteln und dann habt ihr jetzt
gleich einen Mokka Kaffee mit Schokolade
mit Haselnuss richtig lecker und vor
allem habt ihr direkt euer Glas sauber
gemacht ihr könnt es natürlich auch
einfach mit heißer Milch machen und habt
einfach einen heißen Kakao mit Haselnuss
und Kakao Creme und das Glas könnt ihr
später auswaschen und einfach weiter
verwenden ich muss sagen meine Mama hat
auch schon immer Marmeladengläser
aufgehoben und hier ist das tolle ich
habe Glas und einen Metalldecke das
heißt alles frei von Plastik ihr könnt
weiter benutzen zum basteln um was darin
zu verstauen um Lebensmittel abzufüllen
ich habe da vorne so ein glasfach da ist
alles drin denn so sehe ich dann auch
immer was ich im Kühlschrank noch übrig
habe
z.B übrig gebliebender Joghurt übrig
gebliebene Tipps dann kann das einfach
schön verstauen
perfekt jetzt ein paar Eiswürfel
denn ich möchte einen eistmoker ihr
könnt ihn natürlich auch warm servieren
dann habt ihr einen heißen Mokka aber
gerade jetzt noch zur warmen Jahreszeit
gerne auch einen eismoker draus machen
das Ganze hier einfüllen
[Musik]
und wenn ihr wollt kommt da jetzt noch
so halbsteif geschlagene Sahne oben
drauf ich muss sagen mein eismocker
würde ich jetzt so schon genießen ohne
Sahne aber wenn ihr so richtig so ein
ganz ganz Deluxe Getränk haben wollt
steif geschlagene Sahne mit
Vanilleextrakt hier oben drauf finde ich
macht auch optisch immer gleich was her
dann ein bisschen Kuvertüre drüber
reiben
und fertig ist
euer
richtig lecker ich finde vor allem dass
der Haselnussgeschmack und der
Kakaogeschmack richtig gut durchkommt
leichte Süße richtig perfekt zum
Erfrischen
[Musik]
das waren meine drei Rezepte mit der Bon
Marmore Haselnuss und Kakaocreme ich
hoffe sie gefallen euch schreibt mir
gerne in die Kommentare ob Rezept Nr 1
also Schokoladen Cheesecake Rezept
Nummer 2 Schokoladen Bananen Croissant
oder Rezept Nummer 3 der eismoker euer
Favorit ist und vor allem was er als
erstes ausprobieren werdet ich freue
mich schon auf euer Feedback ich muss
sagen ich könnte mich nicht entscheiden
weil ich alle drei echt super fand und
ich finde alle drei einfach so
unvergleichbar und nicht vergessen
abonniert auch gerne diesen Kanal und
hinterlasst gerne einen Kommentar
sonst verpasst ihr doch immer das Beste
abonnieren dann bekommt ihr alle Rezepte
und alle Videos mit
[Musik]
möchte
danke
[Musik]